Speaker 1: OK, something completely predictable
is happening with so-called vaccine passports,
so-called mandatory vaccines.
And this we predicted it weeks ago.
It didn't require any special insights.
I didn't need a crystal ball.
I'm not some kind of soothsayer for realizing
this was going to happen.
On the one hand, we expected there would be
schools, businesses, employers, airlines,
whatever that would start to say after a certain
date.
If you want to do business with us, if you
want to go to school here, et cetera, you
will need to be vaccinated against covid-19.
Now, that was our prediction at the time.
It hadn't yet started to happen.
We also we're seeing some states Arizona was
one that we mentioned at the time, but now
there are more that we're decreasing bans
against mandatory vaccination or so-called
vaccine passport.
So, for example, we covered last week or the
week before that Arizona Governor Doug Ducey
defiantly said we will not have any vaccine.
Passports here are mandatory vaccine requirements.
But of course, it only applies to state government
and to municipalities.
Tucson can't require every Tucson resident
get vaccinated, but of course, that was never
going to happen.
However, we are seeing more and more some
employers, but many, many schools.
We now have more than one hundred U.S. colleges
and universities that are saying to come back
to campus in the fall you need to be vaccinated
against coronavirus.
There's nothing legally complicated about
it.
Before the pandemic, when I went to college,
I had to show proof of certain vaccinations.
I don't remember exactly hepatitis and I needed,
you know, a tetanus shot booster, whatever.
There's been a list.
This has been going on for a very long time
and exactly what we predicted is happening.
And what is that that people in some of these
states, because now you have in addition to
Arizona, you have the Arkansas governor signing
into law of measures preventing governments
from requiring vaccination.
But this is not about governments requiring
it.
Texas, South Dakota, Idaho, you know, all
these Florida, all these different states
are signing different things, banning required
vaccination, but it only applies to government
and some very narrow other situations.
So you are starting to see the posts are all
over the Internet.
They're all over my Twitter.
Every time I tweet about vaccines, they're
all in the comments.
Every time you read about, oh, this university
will require vaccination, that one will for
on campus students, people commenting and
saying this is illegal.
The governor already banned it.
This was written on the wall.
Go back to my commentary from when we talked
about Arizona issuing a ban on vaccine requirements
and I said you were going to have these anti
VAX people showing up saying you can't do
this because the governor banned it.
And, of course, the governor's orders do not
apply to colleges and universities and Ticketmaster
and Live Nation or if the Phenix Suns in Arizona,
they're the basketball team wants to say to
come to games, you have to have proof of vaccination.
Or they might say you need proof of vaccination
or you've got to take a negative test if you're
not vaccinated.
These are two different things.
And we knew that they were going to start
confusing them either deliberately or because
they don't actually understand the limits
of what government can and cannot decree here.
One thing has nothing to do with the other.
It was predictable that it would create chaos.
And we're not even at the point where kids
are starting to go back to school yet by the
time that fall comes.
We hopefully will be closer to herd immunity.
There are concerns as to whether we will ever
get there, but we will should be closer, if
not actually there.
I think we will be doing very well as far
as cases and deaths go by that point in time.
Everybody who wants a vaccine by far will
have been able to get one.
We're getting close to that.
And now it's about convincing people to want
to get the vaccine way more colleges and universities
and maybe airlines and maybe other venues
and businesses and on and on hospitals, whatever
will have said in order to work here, in order
to attend school here, in order to patronize
our services that we offer, you will need
to have proof of vaccination and they are
going to be going absolutely nuts.
How does this get solved?
I have no idea.
I have no idea the the level of misunderstanding.
And it's predictable.
Listen, it's true that even people who aren't
particularly ignorant, if you don't follow
this stuff closely and you hear, you know,
Arizona, Arizona governor bans mandatory vaccines.
And meanwhile, Arizona State University says
you've got to be vaccinated to come to campus.
That does sound like a conflict in some sense.
And it requires understanding that what the
Arizona governor passed applies only to a
city, can't require being vaccinated to go
to the DMV or deny you DMV services, that
type of thing.
It does not apply to Arizona, Arizona State
University or whatever else.
It was completely predictable.
It's going to be absolute chaos.
And I think there is going to be probably
as travel starts to open in other countries,
there are already other countries that are
leaning in the direction of saying if American
travelers, if any travelers want to come here,
you will need to be vaccinated.
This is likely to reach a fever pitch in July
into August.
And as we get close to the fall semester,
there's going to be protests.
There's going to be absolute and total chaos.
And it was completely predictable all along.